>> Jim: ABSOLUTELY, BRUINS WITH
A SHOT TO TIE IT OR WIN IT WITH
12 SECONDS.
JUZANG, AGAIN WITH BALL IN HIS
HANDS, IN THE PAINT, FLOATER,
BACK, TIES IT WITH THREE, GO
GONZAGA HAS TIME TO DO
SOMETHING.
AND ZAGS FOR THE WIN!
OH, YES, OH, YEAH, THE PERFECT
SEASON REMAINS ON GO! THINK IT .
>> Grant: I AGREE.
I THOUGHT WE WERE GOING TO
DOUBLE OVER TIME.
>> Bill: MY GOD, BOTH OF THESE
CLUBS ARE PRESSING, AND LOOK AT
TIMME GOING OVERCOME AND A
WELL-DESERVED -- LOOK AT THIS, A
LITTLE KISS.
THAT WILL BE REMEMBERED.
>> Jim: THAT'S THE BIGGEST
KISS OF YOUR CAREER.
>> Bill: OH, MY GOD.
>> Grant: WOW.
>> Bill: JUZANG WITH A GREAT
FINISH, THINKING THEY ARE BACK,
MAYBE IN OVERTIME.
THE POISE OF THIS KID, TALK
ABOUT HIS DEFENSE, BUT HOW ABOUT
THAT?
>> Jim: THE HIGHEST RANKED
PLAYER IN ZAGS HISTORY RECRUIT.
HE CAME FOR THIS MOMENT, TO PLAY
WITH MARK FEW, A CHANCE TO WIN A
CHAMPIONSHIP, AND WOW.
>> Bill: IN FRONT OF US COME
ALL THESE KIDS ACTUALLY
CARESSING AND APPLAUDING ONE
ANOTHER, AND THAT IS JUST SOME
WAY TO E